[Musique]
vous m'avez raconter la guerre la terre
qui tremblaient le ciel qui brûlait
[Musique]
et ceux qui ont survécu on
qui se sont réveillés dans un monde
différent
où les forts grâce est faible mais ça ne
doit pas être comme ça quand je t'ai
trouvé ton cerveau très humain était
miraculeusement intactes on se sent seul
quand on sait pas qui on met la mémoire
te reviendra
[Musique]
johann hay
à l'état et nouvelle ici elle a beaucoup
à apprendre
c'est un monde sans pitié
je vais te montrer quelque chose
[Musique]
ce corps je me sens relié à lui je peux
pas l'expliquer vous en savez plus sur
moi que venelles dit les lieux de choses
qui ne vaut mieux oublier à l'état je
les découvrirai tout seul
indication fois
[Musique]
mon coeur
elle est la dernière elle est dotée de
technologies qui ont séparé depuis trois
siècles
elles menacent l'ordre naturel des
choses
l'état ils vont s'en prendre à toi
alors je vais devoir les affronter
que toi le plus loin possible
ce soir on joue pas
chausse il faut l'éliminer vient de
commettre la plus grosse erreur de ta
fille
je suis avec elle
balance le sang
[Musique]
biscan d'identification concours
bonjour agents sterling balle selon la
la la la la la la la la la la
[Musique]
ça a marché
le sujet semble désorienté casquette à
feu il ya des pigeons partout et
personne ne les remarque pour un espion
c'est le camouflage du vld en volailles
moi immédiatement
on craque cocotte sérieusement lenze
regarde moi le regarder je peux pas ne
pas te regarder et walter je vois mes
fesses et ton visage en même temps
[Musique]
moi ça m'a pris un peu de temps avant de
pouvoir l'envisager
enfin d'accepter que je n'aurai jamais
d'enfants moi c'est peut-être pas la
peine de le mettre dans votre rapport
un bon candidat l'adoption c'est pas
quelqu'un qui a vécu douloureux dans la
vie on a tous des champs de mines et des
champs de fleurs
nous ce qu'on veut savoir c'est si vous
avez réussi à déminer votre chance
c'est un petit gars voulaient le voir
bonjour je suis assistante sociale
je veux pas le garder
je vous appelle parce qu'on va sûrement
avoir un petit pipi accueillir
probablement demain vous seriez discours
m'a proposé de faire un accueil jarry
que je crois que j'ai arrêté la cage
fait un jour bonjour théo je m'appelle
karine tu éducatrices spécialisées comme
tu le sais ta maman on peut pas
s'occuper de toi dans l'immédiat mais
elle nous a chargés de veiller sur toi
et nous on est là pour ça pour toi faut
continuer à bien voir tu sais importante
du poids
le conseil de famille a donné ses
directives pour trouver des parents ce
petit et où alice langlois sa première
demande d'agrément d'adezaï huit ans
elle est prête cette femme c'est bon
moment pour elle je le sais
[Musique]
je me sent carrément prête
tu grimpes tu grimpes du groupe
mon travail c'est pas trouvé un enfant
des parents qui souffrent
mon travail c'est de trouver les
meilleurs parents possible des enfants
en difficulté
t'inquiète pas ça va bien se passer
tu est un super mec
[Musique]
à votre connaissance votre père avait
t'il des ennemis
voulez-vous que je répète la question
non j'ai entendu répondait je vous prie
je suis la nouvelle servant bridget j'ai
ma belle izzie votre chambre et
confortable il peut faire très chaud là
il est parfois préférable de laisser la
porte ouverte
tout va bien à dos avez vous fait
quelque chose je fais quelque chose de
mal moi si tu as besoin de moi que je
suis
ici andrew gordon
placez votre main droite sur la bible
qui se trouve devant vous
jurés vous devant dieu de dire la vérité
sur toutes les questions ayant trait au
meurtre d'andrew et habib ordonne
bah
[Musique]
avez vous peur de quoi
à votre connaissance votre père avait-il
des ennemis nous sommes en amérique
monsieur chaque homme qui respire à des
ennemis
[Musique]
notre camp et prochain le prochain à
être éliminé
tu as déjà tué non tu en es capable
je ligne
regarde moi bien
quel étonnant sacha alexandre depuis
quand tu es là je peux plus supporter
nous essayons de survie pour nous venger
vous essayez juste de survivre ils vont
tous nous tuer
y at il une zone nominé au tour
ils sont douze
et tous cerveau de sobibor leur
pardonnera jamais ne les tuera un parti
si on détruit les cerveaux pourra
s'enfuir du gant d'ailleurs de courir
des questions
je voulais éviter de te l'offrir devant
tout le monde c'est un très ancien
calendrier de l'avent j'étais à ta grand
mère voulait que ce soit pour toi je ne
paie jamais vue sans un coup cris dans
la bouche je m'en dire non à coki de
mystery un très joyeux noël
josh hill est devenu terriblement beau
gosse sont ni justes ni ok tu as voyagé
à travers le monde à prendre des photos
à sortir avec des gens sympas je déclare
ouvert ses 24 jours de supplices comme
toi je vais avoir le courage de réaliser
mes rêves
à ton avis qu'est-ce qui se passerait si
tu te lances et je me poserai moins de
questions sur mon avenir
alors c'est on veut de moins c'est mon
voeu de tous les jours
[Musique]
des bottes c'est possible il y avait des
bottes et tu m'as en faire des bottes
c'est dingue non je crois que ce
calendrier est magique c'est sûr c'était
un sapin de noël miniatures et au cours
de la journée
la voiture a heurté un sapin c'est ma
faute le vendeur de sapins m'avait
conseillé de prendre des tendeurs je me
disais bien tout à l'heure que ça
sentait le sapin
c'était sa grand père ce calendrier
c'est juste un calendrier
[Musique]
ab je sais que c'est la dernière minute
je pourrais vous venir aujourd'hui pour
une séance
[Musique]
vous dit quelque chose c'est vous qui
avez assassiné mon sapin avec votre
voiture cabine bien rendez vous avec
taille ce soir
il ya ce gars je crois que tu toi duda
moi je suis l'ami c'est pas de bol ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à grand mère était certaine qu'il avait
des pouvoirs magiques elle disait qu'il
nous avait réunis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hu
que voudriez bizarre il a pris 10 quoi
je sais pas j'ai décidé de pas regarder
aujourd'hui stratégie intéressante
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voici le majestueux grizzlies l'un des
prédateurs les plus féroces de la nature
même quand il est le plus vulnérable à
la fin de l'hibernation
oh j'ai encore rêvé que je tai chi minh
a plu je sais pas ce que ça veut dire le
grizzly n'a peur de rien sauf de
l'altitude
[Musique]
non non non surtout pas
non m quatre mois ça gentil coup
j'entends tes amis vous avez bien bloqué
les roues en gros ça sert à bloquer les
roues bavaud non non non non non quatre
lancers du ch
[Musique]
où j'ai même pas une égratignure
[Applaudissements]
on me coupait tout en la parole importe
quoi s'agit-il tout le temps la même
chose c'est parce que vous ne comprenez
pas ce que je raconte
la salle
qui c'est et c'était bientôt mon gendre
alors tu arrêtes de t'emballer on rentre
elle évolue oui comme à chaque fois
qu'une date et il ya un amoureux jamais
je présente a pas vu comment ils bavent
devant la télé à chaque fois qu'il me
voit si jamais ils le rencontrent dans
leur ai dit regarde regarde qu'ils aient
croisé totalement par hasard il est
génial ce mec je n'avais jamais vécu ça
voilà une dernière fois ce n'est pas ton
petit copain c'est le petit copain de
taixing qu'est ce qui s'passe nouveau et
pas largués en plus je trouve qu'elle a
un vrai truc tout entre nous allons ont
été connectés
maintenant je parle d' alex et moi bon
on peut pas rompre et quelqu'un qui fait
moins de 11 secondes au 100 m abeilles
avaient pas confirmé qu'il faisait moins
de 20 secondes si tu veux savoir
ils sont en jeu oui et d'ailleurs
l'amour en quartier la retraite ou
encore dit pourquoi on regarde on le
sait un dieu dans un corps d'enfant
je suis super bolt et à penser à lui
envoyer un cadeau de la part de thomas
schaaf non
qu'est-ce que six ans aux croisés nous
rend pas malheureux de voir à quel point
tu es frustré d'avoir eu que des filles
c'est ce que je ferais si quelqu'un est
brisé le coeur
une poudre au coup de grâce